[Music]
in 1165 copies of a strange letter began
to circulate throughout Western Europe
its spoke of a fantastical realm
containing the Tower of Babel and the
Fountain of Youth all ruled over by the
letters mysterious author Prester John
today we know that this extraordinary
King never existed but the legend of
this mythical Kingdom and its powerful
ruler would impact the decisions of
European leaders for the next 400 years
Prester John Smith would propel the Age
of Exploration inspire intercontinental
diplomacy and indirectly begin a civil
war when Prester John's letter appeared
Europe was embroiled in the Crusades in
this series of religious wars Europeans
campaigned to seize what they regarded
as the Christian holy land the church
vilified any faith outside of
Christianity including that of the
Jewish and Muslim communities populating
the region Crusaders were eager to find
Christian kingdoms to serve as allies in
their war and they were particularly
interested in rumors of a powerful
Christian king who had defeated an
enormous Muslim army in the Far East in
fact it was a Mongol horde including
converted Christian tribes that had
routed the army but news of this victory
traveled unreliably merchants and
emissaries filled gaps in the story with
epic poems and biblical fragments by the
time the story reached Europe the Mongol
horde had been replaced with a great
Christian army commanded by a king who
shared the Crusaders vision of marching
on Jerusalem and when a letter allegedly
written by this so called Prester John
appeared European rulers were thrilled
while the letters actual author remains
unknown its stereotypes about the east
and alignment with European goals
indicate it was a Western forgery but
despite the letters obvious
origins as European propaganda the
appeal of Prester John Smith was too
great for the Crusaders to ignore before
long
European map makers were guessing the
location of his mythical Kingdom in the
13th and 14th centuries European
missionaries went east along the newly
revived Silk Road
they weren't searching for the letters
author who would have been over a
century old but rather for his
descendants the title of Prester John
was briefly identified with several
Central Asian rulers but it soon became
clear that the mongols were largely
non-christian and as their empire began
to decline Europeans began pursuing
alternate routes to the Far East and new
clues to Prester John's location at the
same time these explorers went south
Ethiopian pilgrims began travelling
north in Rome these visitors quickly
attracted the interest of European
scholars and cartographers since
Ethiopia had been converted to
Christianity in the 4th century the
stories of their African homeland fit
perfectly into Prester John's legend
Portuguese explorers scoured africa for
the kingdom until a mix of confusion and
diplomacy finally turned myth into
reality the Ethiopians graciously
received their European guests who were
eager to do business with the ruler they
believed to be Prester John though the
Ethiopians were initially confused by
the Portuguese's unusual name for their
Emperor
they were savvy enough to recognize the
diplomatic capital it afforded them the
Ethiopian diplomats played the part of
Prester John's subjects and the
Portuguese triumphantly announced an
alliance with the fabled sovereign over
350 years after the European letter had
begun the search but this long-awaited
partnership was quickly tested a decade
later the Sultanate of a dal a regional
power supported by the Ottoman Empire
invaded Ethiopia the Portuguese sent
truth
that helped ethiopians win this conflict
but by this time it was clear that
ethiopia was not the powerful ally
Europe had hoped were still the
increasingly intolerant Roman Catholic
Church now deemed the Ethiopian sect of
Christianity heretical their subsequent
attempts to convert the people they once
revered as ideal Christians would
eventually spark a civil war and in the
1630s Ethiopia cut ties with Europe over
the next two centuries the legend of
Prester John slowly faded into oblivion
ending the reign of a king who made
history despite having never existed
we've all heard stories of King Arthur
his retinue of knights and his round
table but was he an actual person or a
myth trace the legend of King Arthur
with this video
[Music]